CHARLES NESSON: The grand jury is dis-empowered.
And in that sense, the citizenry of We the People
is dis-empowered, when prosecution becomes professionalized,
when it's institutionalized and becomes like a paid government function,
in the sense of organization, in 1870 in our history,
the adoption of a professional structure of prosecution.
And that, effectively, meant that the grand jury had a staff.
And that staff was the prosecution.
And the staff eventually takes over the function of the grand jury to a point
where it's no longer any hedge against State power at all.
It's a joke now.
On the petit jury side, a two-step process.
It's the judges, on the petit jury side, who first took unto themselves
the sovereignty of the People.
They assert that the law, as they see it, is the sovereign.
And the jury's job becomes only to apply the law as given to them.
But that was not the original idea.
And then they approve the prosecution.
And they permit plea bargaining, with the result
now that jury trial is more or less a joke, both on the grand jury
side and the petit jury side.